[Musique]
paris la capitale et la scène est en
alerte vigilance orange
le fameux zouave du pont de l'alma à de
l'eau maintenant jusqu'aux genoux sait
plus qui est alors pour l'instant on est
encore loin de la crue de 1910 mais la
prudence est de mise dans la capitale
même le louvre et le musée d'orsay ont
décidé de fermer leurs portes pour
mettre leurs oeuvres qui sont dans les
réserves les mettre à l'abri
laurent blanc et pascal comptons passer
la journée avec la brigade fluviale sur
la scène
regardez leurs reportages les hommes de
la brigade fluviale sont appelés en
urgence la scène vient de dépasser les 5
mètres 20 dont les péniches de nombreux
habitants sont prises au piège
en fait il ya un moment où on sent qu'il
peut plus se débrouiller par eux-mêmes
nous appellent donc là on les voit ils
sauront ils sont sur leur bateau
les amarres du bateau tiennent toujours
mais avec la crue c'est passager n'ont
plus accès à la terre ferme pas
d'urgence vitale
mais cette jeune femme doit
impérativement quitter le bateau je dois
vraiment rentrer à la maison ils ont
secouru je suis heureuse et je les
remercier depuis 48 heures les
conditions de travail des policiers de
la fluviale sont excécrables à chaque
pont la même tension
si tu passes
va droit de la droite parce que tu passe
plus
le zodiac est tout juste passé mais pour
combien de temps encore
autre difficulté les débris en tous
genres charriés par la scène table
souche d'arbre branche
le bateau doit slalomer pour éviter que
cela ne se coince dans les lices le riz
s'est cassé un moteur et si trop de si
on allait trop vite le riz c'est de
partir à l'eau si jamais ça taper trop
fort
les interventions s'enchaînent sur cette
péniche les habitants ont mis en
sécurité leurs meubles mais leurs
voitures garées en contrebas sont
immergés le courant menacent de les
faire dériver
d'habitude on a on a au moins une
journée entre le moment où ça monte un
peu là-bas et là en deux heures c'était
s'était monté plus haut que jamais face
à l'ampleur de la crue tous les hommes
en congés sont revenus spontanément
travail et les cadres et les mécaniciens
eux aussi sont sortis de la brigade pour
sécuriser le fleuve
voilà une montée des eaux pour l'instant
jusqu'à cette hauteur là j'en ai
quelques-uns qui ont connu mais il a
plus beaucoup
donc ça un petit peu exceptionnel pour
nous
les équipes de la brigade fluviale
s'attendent à vivre des heures
difficiles
le pic de crue est attendu que demain
d'ici là la scène pourrait encore monter
d'un mètre
[Musique]